those are the three i want you to check out before
we have full-fledged x-men because they're just
around the corner because this my friends was
the last marvel property before comic con and
there are no coincidences at marvel this is 10
days out from hall h i think hall h is gonna be
i think we're gonna hear that theme
song and i'm very excited about it
reject nation we are shooting this immediately
following the miss marvel finale the finale
for miss marvel was incredible this is going
to be chock full of spoilers for the finale
so if you haven't seen the finale go watch that
first come on back to us the finale was everything
we're gonna get into how this finale and this
show shapes the entire future of the mcu this show
more than maybe any other phase four property i
think is going to be essential for the cohesion
of phase four we're gonna get into all of that
but before we do like subscribe hit that bell
leave a comment i want to know what you think of
these theories i want to know what you thought
of the episode i want to know what you think of
the comic rex i gave you just let me know also
anything else you guys would like to see discussed
on this very show and if you like this show check
out my tick tock i've got 15 second 30 second one
minute three minute more concise videos of these
ramblings that i pump out like three to five a day
so it is chock full of this exact thing but stream
of consciousness craziness with some graphics all
right this is mutants this is a moment we have
wanted since the mcu the x-men spider-man blade
were the trilogies and then beyond but those were
the foundations that allowed marvel to exist
we've wanted to combine those things since the
mcu started since we had this the pipe dream
was somehow having spider-man in there and
we accomplished that then it was somehow having
fantastic four and we know that's coming then this
insane dream of maybe having the x-men in there
and somehow incorporating all these characters
we love into this world and there's been so
many theories there's the idea of maybe the
snap people came back they've got mutation maybe
mutants have been around in parallel universes
and they invade ours maybe incursion events
cause mutants to be from another planet and
mix with ours any number of things that any number
of people much like myself have gone that's how i
i do mutants we now know how we're getting mutants
because we've been living with a mutant for the
last six weeks kamala khan has a mutation and
dinan and that she is a mutant i think this is
up there with retconning some of the aspects of
civil war which is ironically going to come up in
a minute to make the movie work better the thing
about comic books and comic book adaptations is
they need to be adaptations not translations the
x-men universe is vast it is insane the inhumans
universe is also very weird and specific the
kirby-isms of all those things are beautiful and
they work this is nothing against the inhumans but
when you've already got the avengers established
for 14 years when you've already got characters
like spider-man and all these other things it's
hard to do both in humans and mutants so i think
what what kevin feige did was he wanted the people
that are giant and humans fans to have that taste
and we got black bolt in multiverse of madness and
that was a moment of like i want them to get there
in humans i want that for them because kevin feige
is a nerd he gets what people want so i think that
was a taste and i think that inhumans are just not
going to be in this world i don't think inhumans
are going to be in the mcu at least not for like
a decade mutants being how we start to extrapolate
from the world that hates and fears them is genius
so i've been saying this for a few months this is
one of the most gratifying things that one of the
things i hoped would happen one of the things i
dreamed and theorized would happen when it lands
it feels so special not in a sense if i told you
so but in a sense of like i'm thinking the same
way this is going and this is fulfilling a lot of
my nerd adaptation dreams so i've been thinking
kamala is going to go through something that
happened in the comics i believe called kamala's
law and that is when the events of civil war
occurred in the comics as well and through the
sokovia accord they tried to pass this thing where
you had to register if you were a superhero people
took sides tony wanted to as he always does build
a protective layer around the world and he thought
registering people having regulation having rules
was the way to get that through cap was on the
other side of like liberty and freedom and this
is not just and i don't believe in these rules
and that is a similar and then they went their own
way with the movie they only have the comics they
differ from there now what's interesting is that
obviously failed in both the movies and the comic
books but years later more recently kamala's
law is basically okay you you superheroes you
go do your thing we can't control you you're
way too much kamala basically is a child she
gets very very very injured as kamala khan and
they pass a law that superhero children cannot
work and do the super heroics without some
sort of registration this goes through this
is accomplished so all of the champions which
are our young superhero team are basically on
the run they're illegal they're doing things
like vigilantes but fully illegal there's entire
government entities like the dodc as in ms marvel
hunting them down in the comic books the people
that are hunted down the most that are children
are the children of the [__] atom it was right
in front of us the whole time they're geniuses
they're combining these storylines we're getting
children being hunted down because the world that
hates and fears them we're getting regulation
we're getting that beautiful line from a kamala
khan where it says that's just another label we've
had a mutant and we probably have other
mutants because they've established that
we just haven't looked and it's going to be
amazing to see how this goes one of the things
i love is that through comron who is a new human
which is a variation of an inhuman in the comic
books he's always looked kind of like iceman to me
and they made his his power set looked very much
like the comic books and i've always thought
like it's really interesting how it's just
a phraseology of inhuman versus mutants in many
cases not in origin not in powers all those things
but if you're if you're a day-to-day fan if you're
if you're not versed in this you wouldn't be able
to tell the difference necessarily between someone
who's crazy medusa hair was a mutation versus an
inhuman thing they're they're very akin to each
other you know what i mean like certain characters
are parallel this is a great way to streamline
and we're invested because of how incredible obama
vilani is how incredible the show was it gives us
all the family elements that are important kamala
khan's family are so important to her story so
we're gonna deal with the world starting to hate
mutants and how that feels for her we're gonna
deal with other mutants being you know let go
by their family being like expelled because of
this label because of this thing and then we're
gonna also see all the racism of it what better
place to start a show about prejudice than a
show about a very important muslim character this
show addressed head [__] on that the government
keeps an eye on mosques it judges people by their
religion by the way they look who they are that's
[__] prejudice that's the x-men we're going
into a world from a world of prejudice that
exists in our world we live in a world that
judges people for who they are the x-men have
always been a beautiful metaphor for so many
things lgbtq lives for racism for all of these
things that humans do to hate each other humans
suck at taking care of humans and the x-men have
always been a very beautiful very not-so-subtle
look at what that is as much as captain america
is about politics the x-men are about humanity
and it talks about humanity there's characters
like the brotherhood of evil mutants the friends
of humanity they're not subtle bringing this all
in through miss marvel is the best way to make
sure that you're endeared but also that you're
not missing the [__] message that we got to take
care of each other not only does this bring us
mutants not only does it set it up in a way that
feels so natural just like laying groundwork for
these characters just like civil war felt natural
because iron man was so fleshed out and captain
america so fleshed out that when they punched
each punch landed twice with ms marvel were so
invested this felt so natural that mutation just
made so much sense and now we're there so i think
department of damage control is going to establish
these laws i think these laws are going to be
passed potentially in shield i think we're going
to hear rumblings of all these things so i think
while miss marvel is out in space with captain
marvel and spectrum or photon whatever they end
up calling her i think that is going to be going
on setting up the cree scroll war which brings us
into secret invasion on this earth she-hulk
and daredevil who's coming back are going to
be dealing as the first superhuman well she looks
publicly superhuman because she's green she can't
hide it but they're going to be dealing with
the superhuman regulations we're going to see
laws get passed we're going to see regulation and
we're going to see it not just about superheroes
we're going to see it about mutants they've
said the word everybody's heard that the bird is
the word the mutants are here i think throughout
shield we see that i think we see the follow-up to
this first in the marvels then in secret invasion
and then when she comes back that's what all this
is i think her bangle wanted to find its pair
so she got bonked out to space and got swapped
with captain marvel so i think that scene might
literally be in captain marvel to the marvels
and we see the other side of that but either way
i think she just got jettisoned out into space
so we're not going to see her ramifications
of these actions so i think it's a really
important thing to then live in the world of
she-hulk with these rules again this is a theory i
don't know if that's what she hopes about but it'd
be interesting if it goes that way in the meantime
i just want to celebrate the fact that a show as
powerful as this as important as this is bringing
some of the most important comic characters to
us and it's doing it very soon because we've
had six weeks of a mutant on our screens and
that's kamala khan before i get out of here
i want to give you guys some comic recommendations
about the x-men we've wanted x-men in the mcu for
so long god loves man kills this is the comic that
basically made x2's foundation if you love x-men
2 this is the comic for you this deals with the
prejudice against mutants in a very political way
my next recommendation is gifted this is joss
whedon's beginning foray into the astonishing
x-men i actually recommend you read the entire
astonishing x-men run but a specifically gifted
deals with people trying to get rid of their
powers i imagine with kamala khan and these
power things and children having powers there is
gonna be an element of people wanting to cure you
people wanted to get rid of the othering people
wanted to get rid of their problems gifted deals
with what it means to have powers in this world
in that context check it out and then finally e
is for extinction this is a little deeper into the
mythos this is grant morrison and frank quietly
this is the beginning of the new x-men run
when they change the numbering around and this
is basically the government using sentinels and
things to hunt down mutants in a very very racist
way that really hones in on a lot of the elements
of hate that i think are gonna come in to the miss
marvel version of how they bring into mutants
basically politics cheering and hate through
government entities are the direction i think
they're taking miss marvel so what a great way to
kick off comic-con next week what a great way to
kick off the x-men in the mcu and what a great way
to finish with one of the best finales in the mcu
thank you reject nation like subscribe leave some
comments let me know you thought of this video
let me know what other things you want to see and
most of all uh don't be a dick because x-men is
about not being a dick be good to people much love